this is basically a soap opera for great
apes silly as it seems researchers made
videos like this to show that non-human
Apes can recognize that others may have
false beliefs it's part of research
investigating theory of mind which asked
questions like what do great apes like
chimps bonobos and orangutangs think
about other's minds humans do this all
the time we think about what others are
thinking their goals intentions
expectations and beliefs even false ones
but it was thought only people could
understand someone else had the wrong
idea about something this experiment was
set up the test if other primates could
do this
the subjects watched a drama play out
and their eye movements are tracked to
see what they expect the players to do
they sip juice from a fixed straw which
holds them still enough that their gaze
can be tracked the dramatic conflict in
the soap opera keeps the primates
interested they need to be invested
enough to closely watch the scene adding
an ape-like creature reminiscent of King
Kong and some social conflict was just
enough to keep their attention here's
what happens in an ape soap opera step
by step first the human shows interest
in Iraq note the chimp observer in the
upper left-hand corner of the screen its
eyes are being tracked through this
entire process then the mysterious
primate comes in it takes the rock
making a lot of noise as it does though
the red dots show the chimp is watching
the scene intently the human and the
chimp both watch the mystery primate
hide the rock on to the left box then
the human suddenly leaves while the
human is gone
chimp watches the rock being moved the
red dots show all these motions are
being tracked until finally the rock is
removed all together the chimp sees the
person coming back into the room and
reaching for the boxes where does the
chimp think the person is going to look
for the rock according to its gaze the
chimp looks on the left even though it
knows the rock is gone in a series of
these trials all three species of apes
tested orangutangs chimps and bonobos
looked where they thought the human
would go suggesting that these Apes
recognized a false belief in another
mind according to this research
non-human Apes appear to understand that
individuals have unique perceptions
about the world the person doesn't know
the rock is gone so the ape looks where
they think the person thinks it is this
finding suggests that these Apes to have
some understanding of what's happening
in another individuals mind and
threatens to tip theory of mind off the
human only pedestal
you
you